hey everybody and welcome to a messy
wild ride with steo it really does get
messy we've got Snookie from Jersey
Shore and if you think I'm just gonna
like have a laugh or or or make a goof
no I'm a serious fan of Jersey Shore
always was and I was very excited about
this podcast we get into all kinds of
money stuff crazy gossip about the other
Jersey Shore members and what can I say
Snookie is an open book and speaking of
books I want you to know that
today is the release date of the
paperback and I've been signing books
they're available at sto.com only
sto.com can you get the autographed
paperback of a hard kick in the nuts and
got to say this episode is almost as
juicy as a hard kick in the nuts so if
you love Jersey Shore or if you don't
you're going to love this podcast let's
get into
it you actually sleep on this thing yeah
big time I got I got you live here like
when you when you use it you know when
I'm on T yeah I totally sleep on here
sick I love
it sometimes the guys will get hotel
rooms and I'll have the buzz on myself
and I'm so that's nice yeah
privacy okay we're
ready ladies and gentlemen
Snookie that's awesome your real name is
Nicole yes Nicole yeah but but you don't
you don't go by Nicole I mean I do okay
like it's so like my stage name like is
your real name Steve O um some people
call me steveo some people call me Steve
I'm not particular so where's the O come
from uh it just comes from drun drunk
people yelling at
parties yeah got it yeah that it was
really pretty much that simple um and uh
the name
Snookie like that you didn't have that
name before Jersey Shore yeah no so when
we tried out for the show you know you
have to like fill out this questionnaire
and they wanted everyone to have a
nickname ah so my only girlfriend in
high school her name's Katie so friends
with her to this day she's the only
person that ever called me Snookie and
it's from Save the Last Dance okay the
DJ's name was Snookie he was called like
the coochie crook so I meet out with the
guy for the first time out of my friends
so she was like you're snooky I'm like
okay fine so that's why I put the
application that's good and now everyone
calls me snooky and so the the the
application I mean it's just crazy what
a phenomena was and I remember it so
well um and like I don't know
nowhere and uh like me being a guy who
started out on
MTV like the the the financial picture
was so different let me tell you that
from Med
well me our our payment for for being on
MTV
shows the first season of Jackass I I
wasn't even paid per episode I was paid
per bit oh we didn't get paid at all the
first season you didn't get paid not one
penny no well we worked at the T-shirt
shop so we got $200 a week oh so that
was actually a real thing you guys
actually held a job and yeah they paid
us $200 a week and that's what we got wa
and $200 to me for a week I'm getting
every single Friday I felt freaking rich
because you know none of us had money
like that so I was like oh my God $200
to like spend at the bar and like go
crazy so wow it was kind of sick to us
but then we were like oh [__] like
looking back now I'm like oh my God we
never got paid for the first season so
that means you're smarter than I
am well because we got paid per bid it
was 200 bucks if it wasn't dangerous and
it was 500 bucks if it was dangerous oh
that's [__] up and I got I made less
than 1,500 bucks after taxes for the
first
season oh my God and then when when uh
the show came out when jackass came out
they said okay it's a hit MTV wants to
order 16 more episodes we know we're
going to have to pay you so we're going
to give you 2,000 bucks per episode and
that was the point where I was like 16
time 2,000 that's 32,000 I'm rich
like and then uh you know what nine
years later you come along and get
$100,000 per episode we didn't get that
till like season three right okay and
that's when we knew like oh we're a big
deal like we're they're they're bringing
us to La we're going on Kimmel Fallon
like all this [__] so we were like bam
right so we didn't get that until like 3
when did you know you guys were a big
deal was there a certain point I think
so we filmed so we filmed um we filmed
the first season the last month of
August and then we didn't hear about it
till like February when we're like oh
[__] cuz we didn't know like how TV
worked we thought it was going to come
out like the next month so we're like oh
[__] they forgot about us like we don't
know what's happening then we finally
saw the commercial and we're like oh my
God like it's finally happening it aired
and then all of a sudden MTV is like we
got to fly you guys to La we're like oh
like I've never flown to La before like
I don't know I never flew first class so
they threw us all In First Class get to
La the first stop Ashton Kutcher wants
us to come over and we're like so we
went to Ashton's and we did this whole
thing with him he helped us like get on
Twitter cuz that's when Twitter just
came out so right when we knew then like
going to Ashton's and then heading to
the late night shows and doing all them
we were like oh [__] like this is like
going to change our lives yeah it was
crazy crazy ride and like the the you
could see the difference because in the
first season like you guys obviously
weren't known MH and
then the the second season all of a
sudden you guys go out to the clubs and
it just the whole place gets turned
upside down yeah so second season was
Miami and you know Miami is like crowded
to begin with you know walking down the
streets like going all the bars and
everything so it's already crowded but
seeing all the cameras and everything
and now we had Paparazzi we felt like
freaking Kardashians I was like what is
happening we can't even walk down the
street so that's when it got so crazy
that we could hardly like film on the
streets right that and that that's when
you were in a
pizzeria pizzeria was Italy that was
Italy yeah Miami was a gelato shop the
Gelato at that point those those jobs
were like right yeah but the first
season we were like oh my God we got to
sell these shirts so we could get our
$200
wow so it was like really hustling I
can't remember well but was the the fact
that the job was kind of a joke like was
that clear on the show or did they like
pretend like it was a legit job like all
the jobs um well the first season we
really really thought it was like the
you know a real job then the second
season in the gelato shop we're like a
but like we still had to go like they
still would make us get up like our
bosses and be like you got to go to work
so it's not like we could not go to work
like we still had to go we still had to
and we didn't want to be [__]
because the boss was like so great so
like we wanted to like make a money and
you know sell the ice cream but we knew
it wasn't that serious like season one
right okay and uh you know I remember
when watching CU I like everybody else I
watched every single frame of every
single episode and you know I was just
as hooked as
everybody um what what shocked me was
that at the end of Jersey Shore and
which I guess was
2012 like it just it it it felt so
unceremonious like the end like that
like there wasn't like a grand ending it
was just like okay now it's over and I
felt like like that it like it it's
weird it it just it didn't have an
ending I think it's cuz it was so
unexpected cuz I got pregnant so they
were like all right she's pregnant shows
over so wow it was just kind of like I
guess we're going to be done for now and
then after my son Lorenzo I was pregnant
with he was in my belly that seas in
he's 11 now wow he just turned 11 um so
yeah I just feel like once I got
pregnant they were like all right we're
going to take a break or I don't know
what's happening so yeah it went like
that it was just like done and then they
wanted me to do Snookie and jwow which
is my spin-off so that's when me and
Jenny got pregnant had kids on the show
whatever and we did that for like four
or five seasons um and then that was it
for a while and then all the shows
started coming back you know like
friends and like all the old school
shows and then we were like oh maybe
they'll want to bring us back and then
they brought us back and I'm like [__]
we're doing like we're on season seven
now of our new show season seven of the
new show yeah Jersey Shore family
vacation we just started
filming um and and uh and Angelina's in
the mix yeah and and everybody gets
along with her now I mean she's drama I
can tell you that but like I don't want
problems with her and I think she's fun
like when we party we drink she's fun
she's a good time but um you know she's
she's the drama of the show and she
knows it do the producers encourage the
drama back then they they definitely try
to manipulate which we didn't realize
yet because you know like we're all
riled up so they get us more riled up
and then it just goes crazy but now I'm
just like go away like I know how I know
what to do like don't yeah so just like
we're veterans at this point like you
can't no we're not scripted is what
you're asking yeah I mean well I think
there's like strings P behind the scenes
like yeah did you hear what she said
about you see yeah I could see other
people being swayed like that but you
know it's coming me I don't like the
drama if I'm involved in it whatever but
like my my thing was always to like go
out have a good time like I want to
drink enjoy myself like it's all about
having a good time on vacation so when
I'm fighting with my roommates or
there's like [__] going down it just I
like it I don't like drama I know you
said that it's not scripted but it but
is it like uh produced in a way where
they're like okay today you're going to
go to this certain bar after you get out
of work and you guys are going to do
this and then tomorrow you're going to
go to this certain store and back then
it wasn't like that cuz it was like
legit 24/7 we were on camera for two
months straight like going to bed waking
up camera's in your face now it's more
different CU we have kids so I don't
like that like I can't be away for my
kids for more than 3 days um so it's
kind of more choppy in a way to like all
right today we're going to wake up you
know you're going to go downstairs do
breakfast um and then we're going to go
to dinner and then you have this so
they're telling us things that we're
going to do but they don't tell us what
to do in scene we just do whatever it's
not not scripted but structured
structured structur there you go yeah um
you were so deliberate I feel like on
the show like when when when you met
your guy is his name's Giani GI yeah I
was going to say Giovani no Giani joh
and and the same guy the whole time yeah
like you he was inside yeah you you were
like uh like you were so deliberate you
were like this is my guy and you took
your relationship so seriously yeah like
and you take your business so seriously
like it you know it seemed like in the
beginning it was like Wow look this
snooky character she's such a mess and
like you were just so turned out to be
so focused and deliberate I knew what I
was doing I think we can all agree that
it's good to know what you're doing
unless you're not proud of what you're
doing and it's time for me to ask you do
you have a nasty habit that you know you
should quit because that is what fume is
all about and this is something that I
believe in man replacing a nasty habit
with a healthy one I'm talking about
trading in those dangerous chemicals
with flavored air because fume is a
diffusive device which flavors air and
it's a good healthy habit that can help
you kick the bad one and they have a
journey pack this begins your journey to
being a healthier you to get this
journey pack and 10% off when you order
it you go to trf nume.com that's TR r y
f.com and you use the promo code steo to
get 10% % off your journey pack now I'm
just going to say one more time do you
have a nasty habit is it time to tr Tri
fume because I think it is go to trif
nume.com and use the promo code steo for
10% off that Journey pack now let's get
back to it yeah yeah I knew exactly what
I was doing it's and you really were
like that's all anybody was just Snookie
like you were like the like the the
thing CU that was the hottest mess and
the most fun but if you remember the the
first season of Jersey Shore they were
like why do you want to go down the
shore I was like I want to find love I
want to find my Guido I want to have tan
babies like that's the goal here and
then I found Giani and then we had tan
babies so I always manifest my life
that's epic M and um when did all the
the businesses start cropping up oh [__]
right away I feel like I started Ed to
get crazy endorsements in Miami but it
was like endorsements where I knew I was
going to regret it later in life like at
the time I was like oh this is so cool
like a cigarette endorsement condoms
like all this like trash like vodka and
I said no to it because I knew like my
future self I'm not going to want that
you know like as a part of my brand and
my career so I got crazy things like
that but then eventually I was just like
you know what this TV shit's not going
to last forever which it didn't we had
like a huge break I was like let me open
up a store let me um
you know when I got the kids let me do a
stroller line let me do mommy things so
I I always knew I had to do something
and I always want to do something so I'm
not the type to like sit at home all day
and do nothing like I want to have a
business I want to make money I want to
hustle because I've been doing that
since high school that's that's awesome
with uh how many of your businesses are
with
jwow I don't have anyone J none no none
we only had our show together right yeah
um does jwow have a ton of businesses
too yeah she's got tanning um she has a
clothing
line she's um doing behind the scenes
work she wants to do she really wants to
be behind and like yeah she doesn't want
to be in front as much and and she was
she got married to her dude that she met
on the show but that didn't work out
yeah divorced yeah yeah that guy was a
cook H not the best wait no he's a nice
guy but them together did not it wasn't
working it was like Ronnie and
Sammy not that bad not that bad yeah no
not that terrible and and now when
you're shooting uh Ronnie's not in the
mix he comes the season that's airing
right now he comes this SE yeah it's
really dramatic because Ronnie was that
a spoiler alert or what well I think
they might have showed it in the teaser
oh but um yeah he comes and we have no
idea so we're like all when we film we
know something's going going going down
if there's more than three cameras on us
so you have all six cameras everywhere
it's quiet they won't let us like leave
the table I'm like who's coming in so we
knew right away that Ron was coming and
he came and it was just it was dramatic
it was emotional cuz he [__] up he
[__] up a lot so he had to like go and
get help and like you know just be a
better person and a better human being
um so seeing him was very emotional is
is Ronnie now totally sober
he says he is okay but but he says he's
trying yeah so I give him that for
trying but Mike The Situation is totally
oh yeah totally sober I think for like
eight nine years now that's that's
awesome that's awesome which is crazy
cuz he was so bad like so bad I've never
like gotten to that like I've always
been like drinking but I've always been
scared to like do drugs like I'm not
like that thank God can you imagine so
Mike was like really bad you know with
the pills and everything and just
changed him to be a totally different
person so he's just like night and day
now right he's got two kids sober for so
many years killing it with his
businesses like he's he's good and and
uh you get along with him great mhm is
is is Vinnie in the mix still Vinnie is
still in the mix yeah remember Vinnie
had like kind of mental health stuff
going on oh like anxiety and [__] yeah
he still he still gets that right right
yeah and uh of course DJ Paulie killing
it he's the richest out of all of us I
bet huh he's getting all these
residencies he's had residencies in uh
Vegas he travels all around the world
like traveling every single day crushing
it how about that like he really like
like he
uh like if it's like bam on jackass
because bam had the skateboarding and
then jackass was just a rocket ship on
it so
alls going czy and uh and and Pa like
yeah didn't he sign with 50 like after
after the second season or something
yeah yeah yeah he went on tour at
Britney Spears when she was touring he
was the opening act I was like what is
happening it's crazy yeah it's super
crazy yeah yeah and uh Paul Paulie's
like pretty quiet like doesn't want to
like you know he's the loudest out of
all of us but yeah he doesn't like like
he does want to like deess and stuff
like oh no he does oh yeah yeah he's
just too busy how about that yeah but
he's the loudest and he's like the
jokester he's like the class clown out
of all of us do you show your kids
Jersey
Shore like this season no like the old
school stuff like what is there a
conversation to have you know with your
husband about like hey we should maybe
wait till they're this age to show
them no do they know who you are my kids
yeah yeah but I'm an actress so things
that they see on Tik Tok like me getting
drunk and like stupid [__] I said that
that's all fake like that wasn't
actually me so I'm not going to tell
them until like they're 18 like oh yeah
Mommy was a little crazy before you cuz
they're going to know what drinking is
by then like they're going to know but
they don't get it now they like Mom
why'd you do that why'd you do a
cartwheel off the stage I was like it
was part of my acting honey that's what
I do part of my acting yeah all my kids
were born on camera
wow yeah in reality TV they're not
affected by the SAG anything right like
the
strikes so so you guys are still working
through it all we're still working but I
mean Bethany's trying to do the strikes
for uh reality right yeah yeah I saw
that which I mean I would like to get
some extra perks that that's under like
the NBC Bravo Banner but you're under
the vietcom no yeah it's Paramount yeah
yeah it's so crazy was there ever any
talk about doing a jersey sh the
movie I don't think so there's a porno
about
us that's awesome did you see it that
checks out it came out a while ago yeah
like the Jersey Shore porno I didn't
watch it but the boys did and they said
it's just so
stupid wow just like everyone just going
at it yeah but they like kind of look
like us so it's
creepy wow are you pulling it
up put in the Jersey Shore porno so
the like you say that you like to go out
and drink and stuff like how many of the
Jersey short cast members like even
drink at all now well all of us girls
definitely do um Vinnie likes to drink
but not with us so like after we're done
filming he'll like go to Vegas and just
like rage I'm like oh you're fun poly
drinks like here and there not really
when he DJs he does um then Mike is
obviously sober so it's mainly just as
girls being wasted nice yeah well your
girl's night out and and how how
uh how are you getting along with Sammy
oh I love her she was gone and then she
came back yeah she just came back um and
she's been gone for like nine years like
did not want to come back wanted nothing
to do with the show and then eventually
she was back and I was like oh my God so
like obviously you know we all haven't
talked in years so we had to like get to
know each other a little bit again but
then it was like riding a bike she was
like right back into the mix like she
never left right and what was she doing
over the nine
years um running her store she has a
store so just running her store um she
met a new guy which he's definitely
going to marry he's definitely going to
propose um so yeah she's just like
living yeah yeah and and Ronnie's just
been blowing it
he he's in the past he blew it really
bad I think he's really trying to work
on himself but time will tell yeah mhm
when you guys filmed the first season
and it aired what what do your guys'
parents think about all of this like you
guys acting like a drunk mess that's
what I was worried about right when I
walked into the house I said my dad's
going to kill me yeah cuz I knew he was
going to see all the [__] that I do
because I've done it before I got to the
house you know like I just like to have
a good time and like you know at the
time like meet guys and mingle and make
friends so I knew he was going to see
trash yeah yeah was he were they upset
no I mean my mom was more judgy because
my mom's like more like the the
sweetheart like Nicole you shouldn't be
doing this she didn't even want me to go
on the show cuz I was missing school
yeah but my dad was just like Nick go
have a good time maybe you'll make some
money like so I I feel like um my mom
and my dad half and half with
personality so my mom was more like
why'd you do that and then my dad was
was like you're [__]
up have your parents gotten pulled into
the shows yeah they were on the show
yeah back in the day um and they're here
and there with the show you know like
watching the kids or like I have to like
talk to them but yeah back in the day
they were on the show like when I got
arrested I had to call my dad and tell
him I got arrested I and that's the only
time that he was really
mad wow um are then are your parents
involved in all your business stuff they
used to be uh-huh yeah they used to be
like when the when the show first
started because you know I never like
had money before I don't know what I'm
doing so it was kind of like I was like
15 and they were like taking over
everything so I'm glad they did that cuz
they knew where to put it you know like
retirement and this and investing so
they did that up
until um I got pregnant like 24 and
that's when I was like all right guys I
think I need to take over cuz I'm going
to be a parent wow so then I did that
and and what did taking over look like
you want to talk about taking control of
your business then it's time to talk
about ship station because that is how I
sell everything online and it is how you
can make money off of your audience that
you've worked so hard to build get them
what they need man doesn't matter if
you're selling on Amazon eBay Etsy your
own website it brings it all into one
interface as well as all of the
different shipping services with the
best rates that you can get and when we
get an order what do we do we print it
out and then it comes out we slap it on
the book this is how we're selling books
man my paperback came out today and I
signed every single copy and as soon as
the order comes in print the label slap
it on the box get it out the door we got
happy customers and we're making money
and so will you and you can try this
service absolutely for free 60-day
risk-free trial for shipstation if you
go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo again risk-free 60 days hasslefree
it's time to make ship happen so try it
out by going to
shipstation.com and using the promo code
steo now let's get back to
it chaos I had to like hire fin manager
was like I still don't know what I'm
doing but I want to be in control of it
so I just like hired a team to help okay
I wonder if I should do that yes I mean
do you save money or you spender yeah
I'm not like back in the day were you a
spender no not really I would just buy
drugs that's spending yeah right that
but um are you sober now yeah for 15
years oh [__] yeah good for you thank
you how much how much money were you
spending a month on drugs back in the
day I don't know at like uh 5 10 grand
or way less way more
um five 10 a month
yeah way more than that I mean I don't
know I would go through an eightball in
like a couple days what's an eightball
like 200
bucks yeah an eightball last me like two
days so what's so 15 days 15 time 200
yeah but everything else though too like
all the ketamine and the poppers and
yeah and all all the boo is cocaine the
most expensive drug or no n like the way
I did nitrous was
expensive why how much how much is
nitrous I mean I don't know it's like 20
2 bucks for a box of 24 but I would get
a case of 25 boxes so what's 25 time 25
is right what's
nitrous uh nitrous oxide like the
balloon like you get to the dentist like
you inhale it oh so it makes you like
like laughing assas yeah yeah oh but I I
would really really get into it um are
you like fried do you have brain cells
left I I I think me that yeah no my my
brain cells are actually pretty
solid yeah we we did a brain scan and he
has a younger brain than I do really I
was I'm just like what the [__] yeah all
my drugs and and bashing my head May
what's the worst hangover you've ever
had on TV can you recall like like you
wake up like camera's in your face and
you're just yeah I just I woke up and I
just felt like [__] and like back in the
day like I could drink and like it won't
be that bad like now my hangovers are
terrible I have like four glasses of
wine I can't move the next day um but
back in the day yeah they would have to
I would say I need to go to the hospital
I need IV I was like cuz we were
drinking like two weeks straight and
like at one you wake up and then you
start shaking I'm like oh my God what is
happening soz I'm I'm not used to
drinking like like like that so I would
have to go to the hospital like I
literally have alcohol shakes and I'm so
dehydrated I got like four bags of IV
and I had to like stay there for a
little bit so me and dinina usually do
that back in the day and I probably did
it like three
times yeah that's delirium tremin yeah
like no sleeping drinking all the time
the stress of filming being homesick
yeah so wasn't great how much uh uh of
your business is um like branded posting
on Instagram and stuff like from other
yeah companies like you got to get paid
a ton to post on Instagram yeah yeah I
mean I don't do it often though because
I don't want to look like a sellout and
I don't want my feed to be like that so
like if you're going to pay me pay me
I'll do it but if like you're not if
you're going to eh I I say no yeah yeah
yeah I don't I don't have I don't like
my feed to be like that yeah I don't
have any of that that stuff in my
Instagram unless it's me selling my own
stuff right I do that all the time like
like hot sauce oh yeah like hot sauce
that you can get on Amazon yeah we
brought you sto's hot sauce for your
butthole you put on your butthole I have
but but it's more for coming out of your
butle oh [__] I mean it's not like super
hot it's available on Amazon okay yeah
yeah I'll put you on my story oh wow I
got 17 million followers what you got
that's amazing I just hit 7 million oh
[__] how does that make you feel St I'm
not I'm no snu almost almost there I'm
no I'm no I'm no snooky it's it's pretty
incredible it is it really I know all my
neighbors are texting me oh I love it
ste's here I've got a pretty loud tour
bus yeah yeah um I I don't I don't know
uh I don't know what I'm doing wrong I I
I got to Pump It Up um what do you
share I you got to show your butthole
with this coming out
yeah he I wonder I think that that I
just haven't posted enough oh yeah you
got to keep up with it yeah I recently
kind of have been building out my media
department and uh we've got like you
have a media Department well sort of
yeah like because
team oh we hired yeah we we hired
someone to do just the shorts for the
podcast and then now I've got people
working on the social media and we just
had a a like our first scheduling
meeting where we actually scheduled out
like the the whole month like what
awesome good that's usually what
influencers do yeah I think it's gonna
you're gonna be an influencer I know I'm
gonna I'm gon I'm gonna be up there soon
yeah yeah um the okay so so you you told
you told us about you have a store walk
us through all of your businesses yeah
so my store is my main one just because
I'm not going to do TV forever I feel
well I want to but
like I said you never know so I want to
have my storees so I have three Stores
um and then I want like a fourth one I
think in Florida or something um what's
the store called the Snookie shop the
Snookie shop so basically you walk in
and you're just shopping my closet so
like leopard bling I feel like that
could be a show right there I know yeah
I was pitching it and are you wearing
anything from your well obviously from
your closet well yeah my shorts are from
the smooky shop um this is no no this is
BB just my shorts for now um because I
don't have my full closet here it's my
shore house but um do you have online
yeah online so theill online yeah what's
the website the snooky shop.com the
snooky shop.com it's all very simple you
can find me anywhere and actually have a
truck like this well not like this but
it's like a um it's like a food truck
but I turned it into my shop on Wheels
so like people could rent it out for
their parties um or like if I don't yeah
if I don't have a place yeah that's my
store look at the little onesies fore
Snookie um so when people order from
your online store H how does the order
get
fulfilled at my store in Madison or like
all my stores can ship but usually it's
my store in Madison which is like 5
minutes away from my house so I
literally wake up and that's my job
every day I go there and I make sure all
the orders are done like I have a team
obviously but I like to oversee
everything so I'm always like going in
there making sure the store looks good
answering emails like this is like I'm a
boutique owner wow so that's literally
what I do every single day so people can
get a hold of you do they know it's
Snookie when they're doing a customer
service email um no cuz that's not that
that's not that email but um no they
know that they can get in touch with me
yeah so I get a ton of spam emails wow
yeah
um the
uh the the shop is the warehouse for
shipping out orders mhm so downstairs I
have like a full dungeon of like all my
clothes do you use ship
station yeah I used to and then it got
too expensive with all my locations so
then I just stayed with Shopify but yeah
how many locations do you have three
good and I'm opening up a
fourth where I think I want to do well
I'm moving one location to Long Island
it's going to be way better um and then
I want to I don't know I want to go to
like Florida or somewhere nice like
always nice weather Florida yeah and I
was thinking LA but now [__]
everyone's getting robbed like I'm not
taking that chance yeah it's scary over
there so I always want to LA but that's
not happening now Okay so we've got the
stores we've got the online stores I
have wine wine messy Mama wine messy
Mama wine exactly why I helped out on
doing like these cheap promos for vodka
and everything cuz I knew one day I
wanted my own Al alol brand cuz like why
not I'm literally known for drinking and
partying you know what I mean now what's
walk us through the process of that like
the the tasting The Branding all that to
finally get to the final product so I've
been I was shopping around for someone
to do my wine so I was like this is what
it's going to be called this is what the
look I had like a mood board and I just
sent it to all the brand people um so I
ended up working with Summerland wines
to start it off which is in California
so we actually went there on the show
and like we packed the wine
we were like on the belt and wine
bottles were dropping everywhere we were
wasted like trying to like do it so I
ruined like 40 bottles of wine but um I
started with them and then I moved to um
nodding point which is kind of like more
of um just like a website for wine they
could deliver to your house so I moved
to them they're in Washington and they
do my wine now but yeah the wine tasting
I had to do it over Zoom because it was
Co so I couldn't even go there so it was
like a zoom and they sent me all these
like shot glasses of wine and I was just
like nah nah and then I finally picked
like the ones that I love um I got
wasted during it it sounds like Snookie
had a difficult time picking her wine
but you know what I just picked
something and it couldn't have been
easier I picked out my new mattress for
my new property in Tennessee and why was
it so easy because I went to
helixsleep.com
took their very easy two-minute quiz
which matched me with the perfect
mattress for me and Lux that simple and
they're giving away up to
$350 on any mattress that you can pick
from the site plus they're giving you
two free pillows if you go to
helixsleep.com
ssto is not a difficult decision to make
with their easy sleep quiz and you're
never going to get a better night's
sleep than when you're on your Helix
mattress
so go to helixsleep.com
SLO for up to
$350 off of any mattress and two free
pillows and get ready to sleep better
than you ever have before baby
helixsleep.com
sto now let's get back to it but yeah
it's like it's a fun process to have
your you know your own wine it's fun
yeah I what a fantastic name for your
wine messy M messy Mama yeah I wasn't
trying to be like classy or anything I
was like you got to keep with The
Branding messy Mama I'm a mom I get
messy a little bit so messy mama so I
have I have Rowdy Rosé cuz he gets too
rowdy and then I have runchy red cuz it
makes you runchy in the
sheets so I have to keep with the uh
aesthetic of me so those are the two
there there's Rony red and Rowdy Rosé
yeah Rowdy Ros is so good beautiful
branding yeah thank you should we
announce that we're introducing new
flavors of hot sauce if you would like
ooh we got Bane hot sauce what Heavenly
jalapeno sauce for your butthole nice
see we kind of go together yeah we
should do promos
together yeah like have your hot sauce
with wine we're and and we're we're
working on another flavor after that
what is it go ahead we're we we've been
developing a formula called steo banging
buffalo sauce for your butthole I like
it you have a buffalo sauce yet we don't
have a buffalo sauce yet oh that's going
to kill yeah we have the ingredients
coming out people love buffalo sauce for
sure but yeah we're we're kind we're
kind of uh you know on the same Vibe a
little bit is this in stores is it in
stores it's in some stores yeah in
Spencers right it's in Spencers we got
some stores in the midwest Spencers is
still
yeah it's crazy oh Spencer Spencer Gifts
it's it's actually right at the front
when you buy oh I love it except they're
out of it because it flies off the
shelves yeah yeah but we're working
we're working on distribution now oh
yeah so it takes a minute does the does
the wine have distribution in stores no
that's the goal yeah so starting online
and then can you imagine like all those
bottles and like a big cardboard of me
holding it like Snoop Dog how they have
the Snoop wine
yeah that's the goal I I think it's a
no-brainer do do you have rules around
your drinking cuz it's like you're known
for a party girl but you also have your
wine company like are you like okay I'm
only going to drink twice a week I'm
only going to drink oh like personally
yeah it's just whenever I mean yeah I
feel like I don't know like having three
kids it's like really stressful and like
even just like that one glass wine to
like at night I yeah for sure like I I
really like when I'm trying to be good I
don't drink until you know Friday or
Saturday yeah but um yeah I wish I could
do that just you know once a week yeah
you and me both so you don't you drink
every day no no I I used to I don't
drink anymore either oh got it I'd
always promis myself I would good for
you guys yeah towards the end I remember
I was drinking like two bottles of wine
a night but I would like buy frozen
fruit and dump them in and I'd be like
yeah I'm having my my fruits and
vegetables but like a sria yeah and I
would just be eating just bags of frozen
fruit with
wine two bottles yeah did you get fat no
I got fatter when I got sober yeah
that's what happens oh cuz you eat cuz I
started like is it because you have an
addictive personality so you have to
like be addicted to something else yeah
yeah and I I just think that there's
when you get sober there's kind of
nothing else to do like
oh we what am I grabbing for yeah so
what's your thing what what cycling well
I mean my thing that I grabb for like
yeah when when you first started to
become sober um I I put on some pounds
too I got I got pretty pretty chunky um
I would grab for whatever like there
there's this uh snack in England called
pickled onion monster Munch and I lose
my mind over pickle don't monster I just
got a tattoo of uh the the character on
the
back
it's it's you would get that yeah I got
uh yeah I I had cases and cases of those
shipped from England and I got I got
real chunky on that so that was your
thing chips yeah I mean just whatever
kind of food sweets I I'm big on sweets
you don't have any snooky chocolate no I
always wanted a pickle brand a pickle
brand cuz I love pickles and when people
think of me they think of alcohol and
pickles
that I like that um you don't like
pickles when they've got like a little
bit of sweet to it right just got to be
straight D dill pickles no I don't mind
a little sweet I don't like spicy but I
do like the original like pickle like
and I also don't really like like pickle
flavored
things that bothers me like unless it
like tastes like good but like it just
it it it's like an ick for me yeah
when's the last time you spoke with Jay
wow this morning this morning I said
stea is coming over all r i met her
she's like why is he sleeping over your
shore house I'm like that's not what's
happening here they were all so confused
um I met her at I think the MTV Movie
Awards and she was so warm and friendly
to me she is yeah yeah and she's a great
person yeah she and and at that same
movie awards I met Mike The Situation
this was before he got sober oh then he
was was a dick he he was not very nice
to me yeah was he not really yeah what
he say trying to remember like put pull
that up like uh remember I I I spoke up
about it I was like he he cool guyed me
oh he too he thought he was like the
[__] yeah yeah a lot of people said that
about him back in the day what year was
this yeah I was like he dissed
me oh my God that's so embarrassing yeah
that's really funny yeah especially
because I I like when when I introduced
myself to him I was like dude I'm so
stoked on you man like were you so at
this point I I was I was I was like dude
like I I just went there to to give him
love and to tell him I was stoked yeah
and and that wasn't cool to him I like
well especially at like events like that
he's [__] up yeah yeah if it's okay
with you he's nice now can we relive the
moment uh we recently just rewatched the
episode where you got hit by some dude
at a bar yeah how did that go down why
did it happen what happened to the guy
um so we were at a bar and there was
this drunk [__] she's so [__]
annoying like you know drunk guys like
just like too much and
like know but just like just like not
even just like a regular guy just like a
tool he's already a tool to begin with
and then he's drunk and then he's just
like so dramatic so he kept like pushing
us and I was ordering shots and I was
ordering shots for all of us and he took
the shots that I orderers so I was like
all right fine whatever but at that time
we're paying for it with our $200 that
we got from the T-shirt shop so I'm like
come on so then I ordered another shot
um for all of us and he ended up taking
it again so I was like can you stop
taking our shots like this is for me and
then he like said something and I was
like you're an ugly [__] like you know
whatever and then all of a sudden he
just turned and punched me in the face
and I felt like I got hit by a ton of
bricks did KN a small girl H did you get
knocked out I think I got knocked out
for a second yeah yeah I remember
falling to the floor wild and then I
woke up like 5 seconds later and I was
like oh [__] and I thought like I
thought my jaw was broken I thought all
my teeth were gone and I'm like oh [__]
and and they uh they just played it
Isaac just played it on the TV they
didn't blur his face or anything so
everybody knew well they blurred it out
for the first two
seasons wow yeah so it was like a good
fun night yeah so but what happens to
the guy afterwards does he get arrested
like
oh so
bad wow yeah what uh I seem to recall
the the the Jersey Shore boys kind of
mobbing up and going to go well Jenny
was the OG cuz she started slapping him
in the face like Jenny Jenny beat up
anybody that pissed her off so she she
got him good in the face and then the
boys were trying to get to him but
obviously the cops arrested him whatever
but yeah he lost his job I guess he was
a gym teacher lost his job and and then
his father did an interview like 2 years
later or two years two years ago and he
blamed me for ruining his son's life
because he cannot get a job anymore I
was like why is that my fault your son
punched me in the face drink I've
drinking out a lot of bars and and like
my whole drinking career I've never seen
a dude hit a chick like that it was
crazy it's it's insane back then I was
like oh [__] like like I wanted to go
home I was like what the [__] am I do
like this has never happened before but
looking back at it now that's what made
the big hype about our show like oh my
god did you see the little girl get
punched in the bar on this reality show
now would that happen a lot would like
if you guys went out to party for a
night would the locals be trying to
every single night because they see all
these cameras and you guys are getting
all the attention yeah the season 3 was
really bad because they knew if we got
into a fight with them and and one of us
hit them they would try and sue us
happened so many times so it was it was
bad like and they get to be on TV too
yeah so everyone was just using us to
get our money and then get on TV so it
was really hard to go out yeah I wonder
how many lawsuits Jersey Shore had I
think there were a couple for sure none
against me but yeah um nowadays with the
guys who are single is it still a smash
vest no one's single except Vinnie oh
and Vinnie is still a [__] yes isn't
Vinnie like a chi Andes dancer yeah he's
in Vegas right now tripping really yeah
he puts a
and he goes he goes at it on stage wow
so he yes he's the only [__] so uh and
so ply settled down when did that happen
three years ago four years ago wow yeah
so him and Vinnie used to do double shot
at love where they were like trying to
find you know a girl and then he ended
up finding his girl Nikki so they've
been together for a while now so he
found his love on on a reality show yeah
has that ever happened where people
the on show they stay together usually
doesn't last so wow she's a good girl
she's amazing that that that's great and
uh and Mike The Situation was on uh some
marriage show is that right Marriage
Boot Camp yeah yeah Mike did that
Angelina did it and
Dena dena's your your girl yeah you love
Dena yeah dena's my meatball and and
Angelina is like you tolerate her well
she's she's just a she's a lot yeah
she's a lot and sometimes she fights
with me and then she doesn't and it's
just it's it's a lot is she is she like
that off camera too yeah yeah so that's
just like her that's angeler yeah I
don't think you can pretend that yeah
can you imagine if you were like totally
likable and everything was great off
camera and like oh no sorry I got to
turn into a douche yeah because that's
what happened at the reunion with her we
were all fine everything was good then
we got to the reunion she goes [__] you
and I'm like what is happening so yes I
would say she does play it up a lot yeah
but like I'm not we're not like that
like we don't fake things we don't try
and like do stuff for drama so I I don't
know she's a lot for sure yeah so
Vinnie's Vinnie's a [__] Vinnie's a
[__] what what does Vinnie do for
businesses I mean rather than
stripping slang's dick yeah Vinnie
wrote Vinnie wrote books before um just
out here slanging weener yeah he does a
lot of uh he did a lot of spin-offs so I
mean he has like a a a big like condo in
the city like a million dollar condo
yeah so he's he's good with money so
everybody everybody's chilling
everybody's everyone's chilling and um
the
uh TV has just changed so much it's
like it's it's kind of just gone away
like are you finding that people are
watching d sure like streaming on
Paramount Plus or Oh you mean like yeah
cuz people don't watch live TV anymore
right no it's true but our numbers are
so good like number one on Thursday and
you know back in the day you would have
like five to seven million people watch
it it's not like that anymore right yeah
so you're right but um no yeah I would
say I would say live we're still really
good at it but it's not like it used to
be so they're able to squeeze you in on
Thursday nights in between 28 episodes
of Ridiculousness right like can you
just play
us yeah when uh okay so when you got
pregnant and the show had to take a
little break were the other cast members
upset with you resentful like why like
you're the reason we we have to stop
filming yeah well that was like
personally my feeling I don't know if
everyone else felt it but
um I don't think so mhm I hope not yeah
yeah but um yeah that's how it semed
it's like all right she's pregnant let's
take a little break moving on yeah so
yeah I hope not yeah that would suck
where where was the craziest place that
like you've been recognized like I can't
believe the the the show made it here
like for example I was um Kramer on
Seinfeld was like it was the craziest
thing for me he's like I was in
Indonesia and I was like in this Village
and the TV was plugged in there's this
whole village crowded around this TV and
they were watching Seinfeld so like is
there a place that like you went to I
didn't really travel a lot um like I
went to Spain I went to Ireland only for
like the awards like over there like for
the MTV Awards but I didn't really
travel a lot and everybody knew because
I was always like a home body but um
yeah everyone knew I think the craziest
place for with you Steve was in h
Madagascar when we were at that
restaurant that's an actual place yeah
movie Disney just a kid movie yeah no we
had we went to this restaurant it's like
uh it's an island off of Africa oh my
God that's real it's real and we're at
this uh we're at this Italian place like
in the middle of nowhere in Africa yeah
and this guy came out was like a huge
fan of Steve he's like I saw you here on
Facebook and I was like that's crazy
yeah um they have the the um Awards the
European VMAs right yeah like
uhhuh my jackass buddy Chris ponti's
party boy he was he was at the European
VMAs and he was
um introducing some award I don't know
if it was like best video or or whatever
but he he goes he opens up the envelope
the envelope says like Cold Play wins
ponus says into the mic and the winner
is the White
Stripes and so the White Stripes get up
they want do like a Steve Harvey moment
The White Stripes get up they're all
happy they walk down the aisle and then
like right before they get to the stage
he says just kidding it's cold
blown oh my God yeah that's amazing it's
kind of not it's so funny though yeah
like and uh yeah the the guy Jack White
of the White Stripes was I've been noty
super yeah like super not that's
embarrassing too well and the emotions
they felt like celebrating that all and
and and ponus to this day has like such
a deep regret that he didn't just stick
to his guns and give it to the White
Stripes can you imagine yeah it was so
that would have been so much cooler like
dude know the White
Stripes yeah embarrassing yeah um now
how long do you think Jersey Shore is
going to keep going a while a while a
while till I'm in a nursing home
actually that's great yeah can you
imagine me I mean I always said I'm down
for whatever yeah or how long they want
us to go for you never know but I feel
like we're down to do it for a long time
if it works with our schedules yeah
that's yeah and and so so Ronnie comes
back these these episodes H have not
aired
yet like yeah and uh it Ronnie's not in
a relationship anymore right he had like
the crazy one the crazy girlfriend and
and all the like so he had a baby with
Jen who was the crazy girlfriend on on
the season um they broke up and then he
dated another girl that he proposed to
and then they broke up I was like Ronnie
just stop just like do your own thing
you don't have to have a girl CU every
time he has a girl he's in a
relationship he's on TMZ for something
yeah so I'm just like just take a break
just like be a good dad and just like do
you and and um so presumably now
Ronnie's single mhm he's in the in the
mix with Samy
sweetheart and like not technically well
yeah no I mean they're not like together
but they're but they're filming together
and stuff they're not no oh wow they so
this season he only just came and Sam
was out with her
boyfriend which I probably shouldn't
have said that but I don't give a [__]
that's what happened right yeah so
everyone thinks they're going to have
that meeting this season it's not this
season and I don't even think it's going
to be this season filming I mean it kind
of follows right I mean yeah I mean
we'll see what happens there's so much
like crazy history there and yeah yeah I
just can't help but Wonder does is
Ronnie like still having feelings you
know you can't be that crazy see that
yeah you can't be that crazy and not
like have some some that's what I'm
saying I feel like if he sees her shit's
going to like come up again yeah because
of all that history right and and the
producers are probably like yes like
that but they ALS they're also
respecting Sam okay you know what I mean
so it's nice it's nice that they like
see her um but yeah we don't know what's
going to happen this season we're
filming now so is it messed up if I ask
how many of the
OG girls on the cast ended up with
bigger boobs than they started with I
think all of us except
except dinina I cuz I always had big
boobs I only got a boob job because I
had my kids and they just like they were
unrecognizable so I had to get like a
lift and like fix it I'm actually up on
my 10 year I might do it this this fall
um Jenny she's always had big boobs um
but she just got she just got her
boobies done again they look great like
like she always had big boos but they
got like really big oh yeah yeah she's
got like back problems and [__] yeah po
thing
I know it's like we're old now um yeah
so we all got some nice boobies yeah
Angelina mhm should she got I mean but
but who would even notice she gets it
all she got big boobies she got uh the
butt injections she does it all on live
like she she lets people watch her like
get her stuff done is that the mommy
makeover she's not even a mom she's not
even a mom yeah she likes to get stuff
done are are any of the Jersey Shore
girls doing the only fans thing
no honestly I was thinking about selling
my feet wow because there are some real
feet people I heard you make so much
money and I'm like why not but then I'm
like I don't need to do that Paige
vanzan from the UFC do her feet she made
a [__] ton of money crazy I don't have a
foot fetish I don't get it Vinnie has a
foot fetish no Scott doesn't have a
that's one fetish I don't have I just
don't boob vagina fetish Scott has a ant
fetish oh my God pretty understandable
she beautiful yeah
yeah yeah so so yeah I don't get it yeah
the would you do only
fans um you could show your this in your
butt right would I do only fans I I I
don't think I would have an issue with
it yeah would you I feel like you've
been naked for so long well what would
you do on only fans would you like I
mean I don't like I can picture my
bucket l special being on only fans but
you wouldn't like jack off on only fans
but
you I I only jack off on my bucket list
special that' be people would pay for
that yeah it's uh yeah I made a comedy
special where I um I'm in an airplane
but naked with another man strapped to
my back and I'm jacking off and fall out
of the airplane while I'm ejaculating
sick it's pretty awesome it just flies
everywhere
yep it's pretty it's pretty awesome I
never thought about that you wouldn't
now uh okay so we're going to do Jersey
Shore forever the uh the the the wine
like I was surprised to hear you say
that the biggest business is the shops
when alcohol brands are so notoriously
lucrative yeah so we got to build up
this wine business no yeah um I just
started with this new company so it's
going to just like keep growing yeah
so and um what's the the the
distribution model been with the wine up
to this point well I mean it's really
just online because they want to test it
to see like how many people like it how
many orders we get so you always got to
test online first because you don't want
to like do all that work it goes into
stores and then nobody wants it right so
we're there so the Wine's pretty new
then yeah with this compan
with this company and it's two brand new
wines so it's not like my old wines that
I had two brand new wines yeah so it's
kind of like I'm starting over okay so
we're going to tell people right now to
quit being little [__] and buy your
wine so where where do they go to buy
the wine messy mama.com does that work I
don't know we changed it with the new um
yeah messy mama.com put in Google messy
Mama Snookie all right and and that's
messy Mama spelled m
W yes messy what's the website Isaac I
know it's nding point but I don't know
the
actual and you ship all noding point.com
MSY mama you could probably just Google
it and get it there Google messy yeah
like I said it's a new website and you
ship all over the country yes well some
states don't get it I don't know why
it's like wine law or something yeah I
think in the ass those States would
probably be uh Utah and Colorado because
the altitude they have different
regulation for well and even it's like
cuz cuz alcohol is a high-risk credit
card payment so like I remember like
fireworks are the same weed you can't do
across state lines I remember when we
had when we bought fireworks we had to
ship them to Vegas and pick them up from
Michigan so there's like different
credit card transaction rules alcohol
consider fireworks you go to PA they
have the best fireworks but you they
don't you can't buy fireworks in Jersey
can you no not like that so it's like
weird a PA for fireworks yeah yeah like
alcohol is it's high-risk credit card
processing my brother did high-risk
credit card and he was like I was like
well what's high risk and he's like well
he's like when when medical schools need
to buy cadavers he's like where do you
think they buy them from so there's like
rules around the people that you have to
buy dead bodies from where where do they
buy there's a guy that sells them and
you're like well who the [__] is this
guy so yeah the serial killer yeah I
mean they sell dead bodies for like 5 10
grand or whatever it is to that's sick
to medical school you know but it's like
who's this [__] creep that's selling
dead bodies yeah or whatever it's it's
an interesting world like credit card
processing that sounds like the black
market it is they dabble in the gray
yeah the body trade yeah I mean because
you got to learn to cut up on something
that that's like donations I think on
the I feel like before you die you could
say I can be an experiment you know what
I mean yeah I I
are you a donor Steve I feel like on on
your driver's license I'm a donor
because I think it's like after I'm dead
I put a donor I got to be a donor who
wouldn't be he's going to want your
liver I want brain yeah I'll take your
brain who who wouldn't be some people
are cuz they're like my body you know I
don't want to [__] but I'm like dude
take whatever you want yeah you're dead
yeah seriously okay I
um okay I I went to the Red Cross to try
to donate blood mhm cuz I want to be a
good guy you know I want to I want to
help people yeah and and they had a
little questionnaire they asked uh how
were you in the United Kingdom in like
the 80s or the 90s I'm like I went to
high school all four years in London
England so I said yeah oh [__] and they
said that that that disqualifies me why
because it it puts me it makes me a risk
for uh mad cow disease which was a thing
in England at that time oh [__]
I mean I I don't get it but I'm not
allowed to donate blood so you're
useless so I want to what I I want to go
and get a full Pint of my blood taken
out
and have a huge rad painting made with
it sick that cool that's different super
cool what kind of pain sick I don't know
picture of snug a self-portrait no it's
scary
what nothing thank you yeah all right
well um kid we've got everybody buying
the wine thank you big deal did you like
uh we're promoting the new season it
starts September 7th um yeah well it's
on right now the new season oh it is
it's on right now yeah the next episode
is September 7 yes so every jersday we
named Thursday jersday so we changed it
so it's Wednesday jersday Friday um so
yeah 8
p.m. and I don't watch it I just DVR it
okay I can't watch it cuz my kids are
around and I don't know what I'm doing
on there like nothing like crazy but you
know drinking I might be falling
downstairs like I still do that if I'm
not with my kids and we're like away for
a couple days so yeah I can't watch my
kids it's amazing and you only shoot
three days at a time then back to the
kids yeah unless like we have to like do
like a full week which they'll be there
for a week I go there for three
days which means I'm missing out in an
episode and if I'm not in an episode I
don't get paid ah so I'm like can you
shoot me like home like with the kids
while everyone's there so yeah all you
got to do is just hop on a FaceTime and
then you get literally like boom I'm
there my check that's epic yeah all
right and uh what about like personal
appearances and stuff like that like uh
yeah I haven't done them well actually I
have a new I have one um next Friday I
used to work at the Renegades it's the
minor league of um the Yankees and I
used to work there like selling hot dogs
it's in Upstate New York wers and um I
used to work at the concession stand in
high school like selling hot dogs and
everything and now they're doing a
snooky night so everyone's getting like
a snooky bobblehead and all the people
are wearing like snooky jerseys um it's
it's like a full circle moment I want to
send bobblehead yeah I'll I'll send you
one yeah look like me but we we'll send
you a steo bobblehead yeah just I'll put
in my office oh look at
that well that's the old one that looks
more like
me wow okay I can't all right so so life
is good family's good gian's
good and uh we're killing it on Jersey
sh and we're going to have the biggest
wine business I mean I'm trying yeah
yeah I think then you're going to have
the biggest butthole hot sauce that's
right ever yeah I mean but we we do
pretty well with the the hot sauce I
love it yeah and I I think that the
Wine's going to go great because I mean
everybody loves getting loaded I know
yeah except you yeah that's we we love
it we just can't do it we love it we
can't do we just can't do it all right
is there anything else that we can draw
attention to for
you I think that's it all right I
appreciate you coming down the shore
yeah hey you have to come in and just
look at my house real quick I would love
to I would absolutely love to and uh and
I want to say I'm I'm honored that we
got to do this with you I know I'm so
excited this was a lot of fun I genu I
had to make it work yeah
we we thought this was a very big deal
and we went like hella out of the way to
make it happen appreciate it like just
very honored and I'm a fan and and uh
I'm a fan of you I I think think that um
I really really respect and admire the
way you took your approach to it and you
saw it as this is how I'm going to
accomplish my goals you were very clear
on what your goals were and very
deliberate about how you went about
everything and uh you did exactly what
you said you wanted to do and it's it's
just a rad story thank you yeah thank
you it's all about the kids got to make
the money for the kids y that's right I
got to make the money for the animal
animal oh yeah the animals yeah you come
me my dog Rocky I love it let's do it
and thank you again SN thanks snook yeah
thank
you so cute super
fun how about that sto and Snookie the
pair that you didn't know you needed but
you totally needed I mean I consider her
a dear friend now and um I also consider
you
a dear friend man all of you wonderful
people who stick around to the very end
of the Wild Ride podcast you know that
reminds me we got to get that street
team shirt going and uh you guys got to
get this book going man you know when I
read the um the audio book like I read
the whole book for the audio version I
remember thinking dude why am I
admitting all this stuff it's juicier
than [__] and uh I'm really excited it's
now out in paperback and I'm just really
excited that you're here man um thank
you for the love and support and have a
wonderful day yeah dude